You guys ready?
We're all hopping on different
modes of transportation
to explain the design choices
behind the ways we travel.
I'm so excited.
Maybe this was a mistake.
We can now build cruise ships
that are as long
as the Empire State Building is tall.
How do they do that?
You've arrived at LaGuardia Airport.
Why does it feel like
I'm getting less legroom
on planes than I used to?
The US used to have the biggest
and most well-funded
rail network in the world.
What the heck happened?
To find out the answer to that
I’m going to take the Amtrak
from here in Los Angeles
all the way to New York City.
Oh! There’s an RV.
Why does every RV I see have
the same swishes and swoops?
I'm going to the RV capital of the world
to find out.
I just did a crazy turnaround
because I just saw the coolest looking RV.
So I'm going on a little
East Coast road trip...
and I'm 99% sure that
most of the cars...
are going to be bigger than mine.
It's a 70 hour journey.
I guess I better get started.